and don't breathe the main trio is able
to break into houses very easily because
alex's dad owns a security company and
he's able to borrow the keys and disarm
their security systems with the click of
a button this concept is one of the many
similarities to the 2002 film of panic
room where the character burnham is an
employee of the house's security company
and knows all of its weak points i'll
get into all of the homages to panic
room later in this video but for now let
me just focus on the name of the
security company liminal home security
the word liminal is derived from the
latin word limit meaning a threshold
simply puts the burglars have to break a
threshold such as a door or window to
get into the house but there is a
different definition the word is
sometimes used to refer to visual
stimuli in that definition liminal
relates to a sensory threshold as
something barely perceptible or capable
of eliciting a response for example
thieves silently moving around a blind
man's house will not warrant a visual
response however as we know there are
other senses that might help such a man
detect an intrusion as we see in this
movie
no pun intended to learn the hidden
meaning behind the code to the blind man
safe stick around to the end of this
video
[Music]
i love how the spanish title of this
movie is just no respires
i don't know why that's funny to me
welcome to things you missed you know
i'm excited for this one because i'm
excited anytime i get to revisit that
perfect year of 2016 especially
considering the more recent years
don't breathe was the sophomore film of
director fidei alvarez and he would
bring back jane levy the lead from his
first movie the evil dead remake like
another director of a 2016 horror movie
alvarez got his start with a popular
short film on youtube he showcased his
technical skills in atake de panico in
2009 and before long he was on the phone
with sam raimi and making evil dead ends
don't breathe however his next hollywood
boss also seems to have been an
influence on his second movie let's get
into the things you missed
[Music]
the opening shot of the movie shows a
scene from later on in the story where
rocky is being dragged back into the
house by the blind man i had to double
check that this was actually her because
later we find out that she was not the
first woman to be kidnapped by him but
chronologically the first characters
that we meet are the trio of burglars
there's money who has a money tattoo
because he likes money rocky the
struggling young mom and alex the son of
the security system man despite these
three filling these sly cooper
archetypes of the brawn the brains and
the thief they're more of an homage to
another band of thieves junior burnham
and raoul from the movie panic room tap
here for the things you missed episode
on panic room if you haven't seen that
as i mentioned earlier there are a lot
of similarities to panic room and i do
have a reason for using the word homage
rather than the words rip off fidei
alvarez's next movie after don't breathe
would be the girl in the spider's web
the sequel to the girl with the dragon
tattoo which was directed by david
fincher who also directed panic room in
fact fincher was executive producer of
the girl in the spider's web so he
probably wouldn't have hired alvarez if
he felt that he had ripped him off on
his previous movie i mean that would be
like if i joined screen rant
i view it more in tune with how i view
dysterbia as a tribute to rear window or
insidious as the unofficial remake of
poltergeist there are certain things
that make it obvious that don't breathe
is a tribute panic room opens with 3d
titles superimposed on the real world
don't breathe ends with that rocky and
don't breathe has the same hairstyle as
meg altman and panic room money has the
same hairstyle as junior and panic room
and both have kind of a short temper
both feature thieves who target a
specific house because they know that
there's money inside both homeowners are
perceived as being weak but that very
weakness ends up making them stronger
both homeowners are attacked with gas
both movies have a moment where the
burglars discover that there's actually
more money than they thought
both have burglars who unexpectedly
bring a gun both have a burglar that
bails out when things aren't as promised
not what people here end up with me
okay
and both risk their lives to go back and
save a blonde blue-eyed woman everyone
in both movies has an interest in not
getting the cops involved both movies
show someone getting beat with a hammer
and both end with a mother and daughter
looking for a new home perhaps the
biggest homage though is the camera work
when i covered panic room i talked about
the huge flying one shot that
establishes the layout of the house and
does what the burglars cannot but
probably wish they could by passing
through objects walls and floors the one
shot and don't breathe is also really
impressive because it not only
establishes the layout of the blind
man's home but it also sets up
everything that would later happen in
the movie as soon as we get into the
house we look down and see them removing
their shoes for stealth which ends up
being how the blind man discovers how
many intruders there are then we look up
at the skylight that alex would later
fall through then we push forward into
the hammer that the blind man uses to
board up the windows and trap them in
which is also the hammer that alex
eventually uses to attack him and save
rocky then money notices these bells
which we later learn are attached to
cindy who is the blind man's basement
prisoner and the carrier of his
replacement child then we follow rocky
into the closet where the safe is hidden
then we brush past the big lock on the
basement door which suggests that he's
hiding something down there then alex
inspects the alarm which would
eventually be used to disorient the
blind man then we go up through the
ceiling and briefly pass through the
crawl space that rocky would eventually
try to escape through then we go into
the man's room where he's falling asleep
to the sound of a home video of his
daughter suggesting that he hasn't dealt
with her death in a very healthy way at
all and may have other questionable
coping mechanisms which may or may not
be hidden in that basement then we dive
under his bed to see where his gun is
hidden which he would later use to come
after them before finally we see him and
money entering his room to gas him out
that is all one shot and it sets up
every other scene that takes place in
the house it's also a big reason that
this scare a moment later is so
impactful even though he's just sitting
there because we've just been through
three minutes and 16 seconds without a
cut and we're not really expecting one
anymore there are other potential
foreshadowing moments and one secret
that you need to see this deleted scene
to fully understand
[Music]
at the first house that they break into
alex starts by grabbing a pair of
headphones perhaps a clue that sound
plays a huge role in this movie he also
grabs a book fool's gold by dolores
hitches a 1958 novel about two teen
delinquents and a girl who try to rob a
house that looks like it's gonna be an
easy job but they find themselves in
trouble after getting wrapped up with
some older more experienced thieves
there is a movie adaptation of fool's
gold a french picture called band of
outsiders and thanks to my french new
wave class in college i have seen it
there's a scene in that movie where the
characters are dancing to music from a
jukebox at a restaurant
[Music]
don't breathe actually has a deleted
scene where rocky steals a waitress's
tip and her and alex start dancing to
cover it up and they discuss the ethics
of their next job lo and behold the song
on the jukebox is a sped up version of
the song from band of outsiders
you doing
dancing
anyway the other book on the shelf next
to fool's gold is called light of day by
graham swift just the title alone makes
me think of rocky escaping into daylight
at the end of the movie there's also a
part where money can be seen spraying
some of his
uh
cleaning fluids onto the floor not a
great idea considering that stuff
contains dna and this is about to be a
crime scene but it's an interesting
choice because the blind man happens to
have his own freezer full of cleaning
fluids hidden down in his basement to
try to pass his own dna down to a new
generation money is not the only
character who isn't the smartest kid
rocky's plan is to steal the money and
use it to move her and her daughter to
california
all right this guy
is sitting on at least 300k if we do
this right
we never have to do it again
so that's what 100k each i mean that's
not going to pay the bills for very long
in california i think the intention here
is to show that these characters are
still dumb teenagers it's kind of like
an it follows how the kids come up with
this ridiculous plan which obviously
doesn't work but it's still believable
that they'd be dumb enough to attempt it
also both movies take place in detroit
so there must be something in the water
over there in michigan
there are a couple of more interesting
setups and instances of foreshadowing
early on rocky explains the meaning of
her ladybug tattoo how her mother used
to lock her in the trunk of her car and
a ladybug flew in through a hole to
comfort her this may be what gave her
the idea to lock the dog in the trunk
when it comes after her at the end they
read the article about how the blind man
came upon his windfall by reaching a
settlement with the family of his
daughter's killer if you look closely
you'll see that the article is written
by zoltan berta this is an easter egg
put in by zoltan himself he's the motion
graphic designer on don't breathe he was
also probably responsible for adding in
this date september 29 2016. i remember
that day it's the day the cubs pirates
game ended in a tie something i didn't
even know was possible until it happened
ultimately that means nothing for the
movie but there is another date that is
more significant the combo to the safe
both safes actually the one in the
closet and the one in the basement is
2978. according to imdb this is the
birthday of director fidei alvarez
february 9th 1978. but besides that
there are just so many great details
that make more sense on repeat viewings
like how the dog is chained up next to
the basement hatch and how the movie
shows us that it's locked even on the
inside i guess money was right about one
thing just cause he's blind don't mean
he's insane bro it's interesting how the
blind man's disability can actually be
an advantage for him in this case money
doesn't see him as as much of a threat
causing him not to shoot when he had the
chance and he gains an advantage over
alex and rocky by turning off the lights
because he's already used to navigating
the house with no vision side note i
love the look of the scene in the dark
the filmmakers effectively communicate
darkness without making the screen black
and without using that green night
vision looking filter very creative
scene rocky eventually escapes the house
but after outwitting the blind man's dog
she's captured again and dragged back
inside as she's laying there she kind of
goes out of focus it's almost like she's
giving up and her own vision is starting
to fade but this causes her to see the
ladybug which helps her out once again
because when she looks over at it she
realizes how she can neutralize her
opponents using the alarm the tactics
that they use against each other are a
lot like the chess match that i talked
about when discussing panic room the
barrage of sound drives the blind man
crazy and he shoots the gun wildly
accidentally hitting a mantle photograph
of his daughter which is symbolic of the
fact that his last chance to carry on
his lineage is about to escape from it
it may not have been his last last
chance though because there is going to
be a sequel
now i've personally been avoiding the
previews so i can go in blind pun
intended but once it's available i'll
probably be covering it here on things
you missed so make sure you subscribe to
cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell for notifications
even if you're not a basement prisoner
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive so get
vaccinated
[Music]
you